in this tautological movement the
understanding as we have seen sticks to
the inner unity of its object and the
movement falls only within the
understanding itself not within the
object it is an explanation that not
only explains nothing but is so plain
that while it pretends to say something
different from what has already been
said really says nothing at all but only
repeats the same thing in the thing
itself this movement gives rise to
nothing new it comes into consideration
only as a movement of the understanding
in it however we detect the very thing
that was missing in the law that is the
absolute flux itself for this movement
when we look at or closely is directly
the opposite of itself that is to say it
posits a difference which is not only
not a difference for us but one which
the movement itself cancels it has a
difference this is the same flux which
presented itself as the play of forces
the contain this contained the
distinction of soliciting and solicited
force or force expressing itself and
force repressed into itself but these
were distinctions which in reality were
no distinctions and therefore were also
immediately canceled again what is
present here is not merely bare unity in
which no difference would be positive
but rather a movement in which a
distinction is certainly made but
because it is no distinction is again
canceled in the process that of
explaining the to infer of change which
before was outside of the inner world at
present only the appearance has
penetrated into the supersensible world
itself our consciousness however has
passed over from the inner being as
object to the other side into the
understanding and an experience has
changed there
leading through section 154 which we
just finished we found out that the law
and force two things that we've been
studying very extensively have the same
structure but they have the same
structure as it's revealed for the
understanding it's very important to
remember this chapter is force and the
understanding and when Hegel's gonna
refer to this later on he's not going to
talk very much about force he's not
going to just talk about law he's going
to talk about you know sense perception
perception and then understanding as a
faculty so what is the understanding
actually achieve we're gonna see this
consolidated in this section 155 and in
156 and then finally in 157 we're gonna
see it lead into something else so he
says there's a tautological movement
what is a tautology it's when you're
singing the same thing sometimes in a
disguised way now for example when you
say a Bachelor is an unmarried male as
if somehow you're conveying some
information about it really you're
saying Bachelor is a Bachelor right or
if you're saying you know one plus one
equals two well that's what 2 is so when
we're saying that there's a tautological
movement in saying that law and force
two have the same structure or in the
other things that we're going to talk
about here what's going on is that
there's an appearance of conveying
information there's an appearance of
proceeding with inquiry but as we're
going to see in this this particular
section that appearance gives way I
should really shouldn't use the word
appearance because we're talking about
the world of appearance here that
semblance gives away that assumption
gives way to the realization that we're
not actually making any significant
advances in the Hegelian dialectics
sometimes to realize that you haven't
made a significant advance is itself a
significant advance as part of something
else
and we're going to see that happening
here so I put consciousness here at the
end of this section we're gonna see and
discussion that correlates the
understanding and the inner or
supersensible world and so we want to
keep that in mind and what are they
being focused upon or what are they
being contrasted to the inner world the
supersensible world is being contrasted
against the world of appearance the
world of change the world of the thing
the thing that we're actually perceiving
the thing that we're looking at you know
the understanding is what has taken that
in remember the understanding is this
faculty that not only perceives but also
allows us to make sense of the things
that allows us to have concepts of
things it allows us to figure out what
kind of thing they are and how change
works now there's a movement that goes
on between these now here's where we
want to go back to the text he says in
this tautological movement the
understanding sticks to the inner a
unity of its object and the movement
falls only within understanding itself
not within the object so we think that
there's a movement going on within the
thing but it's really what we're
bringing to it it's really the
perspective that we're contributing in
which this dialectical movement is
taking place so he says it's an
explanation that not only explains
nothing but it's so plain that while it
pretends to say something different from
what has already been said really says
nothing at all but only repeats the same
thing you know if you want to be jokey
here we've you know repeating the same
thing that's a tautology that's two
different ways of saying the same thing
there so in the thing itself this
movement gives rise to nothing new why
not well in part because the movement
isn't really taking place within the
thing itself the movement is really
taking place fundamentally within
understanding within our consciousness
of what's going on so it's a movement in
certain respects that's less of the
object and more pertaining to the
subject in its perspective upon the
object so he says it comes into
consideration only as a movement of the
understanding in it in that
movement we detect the very thing that
was missing in the law so here's where
we're actually making some sort of
dialectical progress in looking at this
movement and understanding that it's
something that pertains to the
understanding we ask this key question
what was missing in the law now think
back to what a law is supposed to do in
this section at least Oh wha unifies a
law brings together a whole bunch of
individual circumstances and in a
certain sense homogenizes them it takes
in a whole manifold of differences and
then D differentiates them and says well
these are all the same sort of thing
they all fall under this case we can
deal with them all in this way we saw
that there's a dialectic involved in
that where you know there's laws and law
and you know there's an interplay
between those as well here what we're
interested in is something like a limit
condition what Hegel is denoting as
absolute flux we've seen this already
when we talked about the difference of
difference or absolute difference itself
that's something that the law cannot
adequately take into account and yet at
the same time it's required to we might
say the law compels the law ought to do
so but Hegel is not going quite so far
with that if there is anything that's
doing that compulsion it's the
understanding but this hasn't been yet
made totally explicit so what can we say
about this this realization of the
absolute flux that that was missing in
the law he says them this movement when
we look at it more closely is directly
the opposite of itself so the movement
that we've been churning out produces
its own self opposition what else can we
say he says it's a difference or it
bears upon a difference that's not a
difference for us a difference that
appears to be a difference a difference
that comes on the scene and makes us
zooom that it's a difference that makes
a difference and then when we further
follow it out we've realized that
difference actually doesn't matter that
much and that's part of what goes into
law right law takes differences and says
well yeah I understand they're different
but they don't really matter insofar as
they're different from each other
we just take them in and make sense of
them what else the difference he says is
cancelled as such so let's look at what
he says there it says it posits a
difference which is not only not a
difference for us but one which the
movement itself cancels is difference
now you could say well why don't we just
cut to the chase and just say well look
it's not a difference and now we can
just go home well that's not the
dialectical process there's something
that is gained by the subject that is
consciousness here or you and me
following along with Hegel realizing
that in this movement
there's the differences cancelled out
it's still a movement like I put here
but it's a movement that cancels the
distinctions that are being made in the
course of the movement so there's kind
of a back and forth involved in this and
again you might say well why not just
cut to the chase and just you know
cancel out the whole thing here we want
to think in terms of determinate
negation which is an Italian concept
when you negate the negation you don't
wind up back at the start it's not as if
two minuses automatically make a
positive they make a different positive
right we saw this way back in the
preface so he says what else can we say
about this this is the same flux which
presented itself as the play of forces
so we're not just talking about law
again we're talking about force this
contained the distinction of soliciting
and solicited force our force expressing
itself and force repressed into itself
and these are examples of what he says
no distinctions distinctions which in
reality were no distinctions and which
were canceled now we couldn't just
cancel them from the start we had to go
through them and see that what we
thought we had is hard and fast
distinctions just kind of fell apart
they didn't show themselves as being
essential
fundamental so he says what is present
here is not merely bear unity in which
no difference would be positive but
rather a movement in which a distinction
is certainly made but because it's no
distinction is again canceled so in the
process that of explaining the
to-and-fro of changed that's what we're
trying to make sense of here which was
before outside of the inner world and
present only the appearance has
penetrated the inner world into the
super sensible world our consciousness
he says has passed over from the inner
being his object to the other side into
the understanding we're now becoming
conscious of our own role involved in
this and where that's making some
progress here it experiences change in
the understanding so change which is now
in both the thing and the world of
appearance and the inner world is also
happening within the understanding
thus this change is not yet a change of
the thing itself but rather presents
itself as pure change by the very fact
that the content of the moments of
change remains the same but since the
notion qua notion of the understanding
is the same as the inner being of things
this change becomes for the
understanding the law of the inner world
the understanding does learns that it is
a law of appearance itself that
differences arise which are no
differences or that it what is self same
repels itself from itself and similarly
that the differences are only such as
are in reality no differences and which
cancel themselves in other words what is
not self same is self attractive and
thus we have a second law whose content
is the opposite of what was previously
called law that is difference which
remains constantly self same for this
new law expresses rather that like
becomes unlike and unlike becomes like
the notion demands of the thoughtless
thinker that he bring both laws together
and become aware of their antithesis the
second circuit is certainly also a law
an inner self identical being but a self
sameness rather of the unlike permanence
of impermanence in the play of forces
this law showed itself to be precisely
this absolute transition and pure change
the self same that is force splits into
an antithesis which at first appears to
be an independent difference but which
in fact proves to be none for it is the
self same which repels itself from
itself and therefore what is repelled is
essentially self attractive for it is
the same the difference created since it
is no difference
therefore cancels itself again
consequently the difference exhibits
itself as difference of the thing itself
or as absolute difference and this
difference of the thing is thus nothing
else but the self same that is repelled
itself from itself and therefore merely
posits an antithesis which is not
in section 156 Hegel is really at his
Hegelian prime which is why I think a
lot of people are going to find this
section rather confusing in two
different ways one it's hard to follow
the twists and turns of where he's going
what we might call the structure of the
movement that he's going through in this
section and then it's also hard to
figure what is he actually trying to get
at here and that is what we might call
the the content or the the goal of this
section so notice we're gonna start out
here with this schema Hegel we've talked
about change and this this movement that
turns out to be you know involving self
cancellation all these sorts of stuff in
the last section but what is he getting
at with that so he says the changes not
get a change of the thing and we'll
bring the thing in and at the end of
this section but rather presents itself
as pure change by the very fact that the
content of the moments of change remain
the same right what is any the content
of the moments of change remains the
same so we're kind of shuffling deck
chairs around on the Titanic if you you
know like that metaphor then he says but
the the notion qua notion of the
understanding is the same as the
intervening of things so we've got this
connection between the understanding and
the intervening of things the inner
world the supersensible world which is a
world of laws as we're gonna see he says
it's that this change becomes for the
understanding the law of the inner world
so change pure change is the mediating
factor which is now allowing us to bring
together the understanding our faculty
as a subject in the law of the inner
world these super sensible eternal fixed
for all time laws these intelligibility
x' that we are trying to you know get at
through the appearances that's the old
eternal promise isn't it of philosophy
to find out what is
that which is and remains and will be so
Hagel is beginning there but notice that
it's change that reveals that to us it's
not just looking at the unchanging it's
by looking at the world of flux the
world of appearance that we're going to
get to the inner world the supersensible
so he says the understanding thus
learned that it is a law the
understanding is a law but what kind of
law here's an important point a law of
appearance now let's pause for a moment
we've talked a lot about law in the
previous sections when we think of law
we tend to think in terms of this as
what's lying behind the appearances
what's uniting them what's turning their
differences into not really being
differences what is going to always hold
what is going to encompass all of these
these changing things and sort of suck
the change out of them and get to the
eternal marrow but if we really want to
get at reality we have to acknowledge
that appearance and change aren't just
illusions they're not just in
essentiality according Hegel at least
there's a law of appearance that law he
he specifies in a number of ways
he says differences arise which are no
differences what do we mean by that well
they appear to be differences right this
is a world of appearance we assume them
to be different so as we act towards
them as if they're differences and then
as we go through and we learn and we
experience we find out that they aren't
really differences that they are brought
on to it you know brought together in
some sort of system or they have more in
common with each other than we thought
he starts getting very metaphysical here
he says the self-same repels itself from
itself that's under the law of
appearance that's under the law of
change this
self-same that which is identical that
which is and will continue to be what
we've got over here
repels itself from itself this isn't
that movement of self uttering of
producing its own opposition that we see
as at the very heart of the Galleon
dialectic
he also says furthermore what is not
self same so what is generated in the
process of the self same uttering itself
what is not self same is self attractive
there is a fundamental dynamism and also
contradiction within the heart of being
and beings itself that brings together
the things that aren't the same and
takes what is the same and sunders it
within itself and this is a back and
forth back and forth kind of motion he
expresses this another way like becomes
unlike this is a law of appearance a law
of becoming a law of the world of change
like becomes unlike unlike becomes like
as like becomes unlike its splitting
from itself and then the parts that are
unlike can then reunite and become
something perhaps greater or just
destroy each other or something
different at leas unlike becomes like
now this is very different than this
this understanding of law over here so
he said we have two different distinct
kinds of law here and remember what
happened before when we talked about a
plurality of laws what was the dynamic
that occurred in that case we said well
that's not really gonna work is it
because it's gonna be law they've got to
be able to be integrated with each other
there has to be some sort of overarching
higher law the concept of law the notion
of law that will bring them together and
then we found out that was rather empty
we have this back and forth earlier on
with you know the laws that were
specific and then
the law that is capital L brings them
together but it's kind of abstract and
hard to get our heads around and how
everything is actually connected with
each other well we've got something
similar going on here hey we'll talk
about antithesis you could just as well
say opposition and he's also going to
talk about difference now what is going
to actually realize the fact that
there's two laws and trying to unite
these together that's the understanding
so he says the notion here we have to
think in terms of the draft all right
concept or notion demands that the
thoughtless thinker bring both laws
together and become aware of their
antithesis as we've been thinking
through this we by the way out of the
photo sticker has we've been thinking
through this we've been working with
this law we've got this law now and now
we should have an eye on a moment and
say or actually more like an oh crap
woman what are we going to do now how
are we going to unite these how are we
going to bring these together
notice that this law by itself is not
compatible with this water nor is this
law compatible with this law what can
bring them together is the thinking
conscious subject we are able to
integrate opposition's even antipathy
antitheses even contradictions within
our own thought that is part of what
makes us us by the way we're gonna see
that very importantly as we move into
further sections like self consciousness
so he says the second is certainly a law
right the law of appearance is a law an
inner self identical being that's what a
law is for for Hegel here but a self
sameness rather than like a permanence
of impermanence so we have two different
permanence --is of impermanence going on
this one right here which is you know
what's supposed to lie behind the
appearances this one right here which is
giving us the appearances of
way ultimately we want to see these as
two sides of the same coin or two things
that sort of fit into each other like
puzzle pieces so he's he again he's
going to use force right he says in the
play of forces his law shown itself to
be precisely this absolute transition
and pure change of self same force we
saw that that play itself out splits
into an antithesis which at first
appears to be an independent difference
which in fact proves to be none that's
up here for it is the self sandwich
repels itself from itself and therefore
what is repelled is essentially self
attractive for it is the same this
entire process of going back and forth
like this and splitting into these two
aspects happened with forest now it's
happening with law the understanding has
to bring these together so he goes on
and he says consequently the difference
exhibits itself as a difference of the
thing okay how do we we're going to
bring back the thank the difference
exhibits itself is a difference of the
thing itself or it's absolute difference
and this difference of the thing is this
nothing else but the self same that is
repelled itself from itself and
therefore merely posits and antithesis
which is not an antithesis between this
law and this law now notice one thing
though before we close in this section
this law can't make sense of this law
can't this law if we were to use this as
our conceptual apparatus can in fact
make sense of this law as something that
is different that is other than and it
could even is so to speak if we want to
be anthropomorphic desire it could be
attracted to what is different than it
and this law can take account of the
opposition it can actually provide us
with the outline of the movement that's
taking place that should tell us that
this in certain respects has a priority
over this and that this is going to
somehow become integrated to that
this principle the first supersensible
world the tranquil kingdom of laws the
immediate copy of the perceived world is
changed into its opposite the law was in
general like it's differences that which
remain self same now however it is
positive that each of the two worlds is
really the opposite of itself the self
same really repels itself from itself
and what is not self saying really
posits itself as self saying in point of
fact it is only when thus determined
that the difference is inner difference
or the difference in its own self the
light being unlike itself and the unlike
like itself this second super sensible
world is you know in this way the
inverted world and moreover since one
aspect is already present in the first
super sensible world the inversion of
the first with this the inner world is
completed as appearance for those first
super sensible world was only the
immediate raising of the perceived world
into the universal element it had its
necessary counterpart in this perceived
world which still remained for itself
the principle of change and alteration
the first kingdom of laws lacked that
principle but it attains it as an
inverted world
here in section 157 Hegel begins to
develop the notion that is probably the
most famously associated with this
section force in the understanding that
of the inverted world as a matter of
fact I've mentioned before that this is
one of the most difficult sections
Hegel's phenomenology and many people
that sort of blazed through it so they
can get to the other side and get to the
you know self consciousness stuff that's
going to follow quite soon and this
tends to be the one thing that they do
remember from this section that there's
an inverted world that's the opposite
you know sort of like bizarro land we're
going to explore that a minute but we
want to look at in this case is how that
inverted world actually develops out of
the interplay between the two other
worlds and remember - all of these are
going to be united together by
consciousness in one world that we
actually live in these are different
aspects of it so we start with the
opposition between the perceived world
and the supersensible world which we're
going to recognize now as being just the
first supersensible world he says this
the first supersensible world the
tranquil kingdom of laws the immediate
copy of the perceiver world is changed
into its opposite let's remind ourselves
of what this first supersensible world
is like it's static it's eternal it has
the laws behind the appearances and it
is self same it is the the realm of the
self same for Hale but we just saw that
the self same can't remain self saying
that there's a movement inherent to
identity itself that produces difference
within the Hegelian dialectic the
perceived world is a world of
appearances Hegel is going to say a
little bit later on that it retains the
principle of change an alternation
that's going to turn out to be quite
important the perceive the world gives
us the supersensible world in part
because we say well the laws can't
really - here they have to be here
that's where we're looking for them and
they understanding grasps this you know
and you can play around with this a lot
of different ways you can think about
this
in terms of play-doh or contour whoever
but you know the basic idea is that
there's there's two worlds here and
somehow they're connected up with each
other but this world is kind of like a
copy of this world so he says the law
was in general like its difference is
that which remains so same now however
it's posited that each of the two worlds
is really the opposite of itself so the
perceived world the world of appearances
is is the opposite of itself well it can
have that opposition here can't it but
where can this have its opposition this
has to have its opposition somewhere
else so he says the self-same repels
itself from itself what is not so same
really posits itself as self saying and
we're going to get another super
sensible world so he says in point of
fact it is only when thus determined
that the difference is inner difference
or the difference in its own self
this second super sensible world in is
in this way the inverted world the
inversion the flipping the you know
where things are like they become unlike
where they are unlike they become like
this is where the play of identity and
difference from this world is happening
over here
Hegel is going to treat this in a way
that that's going to seem a little bit
formulaic as we go into it but we don't
don't worry about that quick yeah so he
says with this the inner world is
completed as appearance for the first
super sensible world was only immediate
raising of the perceived world into the
universal element that was important
right we accomplished something by
raising it into its universal element
and then by reuniting these two it's
necessary counterpart in this perceived
world which still retained for itself
the principle of change in alternation
now this is going to be the inverted
world not only of this but also of this
as well this second inverted world is
what is going to help us reunify the
world of perception and appearance and
the word
of the understanding and laws